voilà un coup de colère qui n'est pas
resté sans réaction aujourd'hui on va
l'entendre
alors qui a raison qui a tort les
emplois ont ils été supprimés y at il
moins d'enfants handicapés scolarisés
réponse avec françois beaudonnet et
dominique bonnet 24 heures après le
débat la polémique sur la scolarisation
des enfants handicapés ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur
14h aujourd'hui des ministres de
l'éducation et de la santé improvisent
une grande conférence de presse il
dévisse de ségolène royal des excuses
c'était un coup politique malone est
basée sur ce qui a de plus sensible pour
celles et ceux qui ont apporté un enfant
handicapé
et oui moi je suis sincèrement en colère
parce qu'on a cherché à tromper les
français
une heure et demie plus tard au siège du
parti socialiste
autre conférence de presse en urgence et
autre version des faits je persiste et
je signe
la qualité de l'accueil quand ils sont
accueillis ils ne sont pas toujours des
enfants handicapés n'est pas assurée
trop de bricolage ou d'amateurisme trop
de précarité qui dit donc la vérité les
sept mille postes d'emploi jeunes ont
ils été supprimée comme l'affirmé
ségolène royal oui mais ils ont été
remplacés alors c'est parce qu'ils sont
souvent précaires ont été je dirais
plutôt transformé ça a été transformée
cahin caha avec des périodes de latence
mais en fait ils ont changé de nom il
s'appelait autrefois emplois jeunes et
s'appelle aujourd'hui assistant de vie
scolaire
les associations de parents d'enfants
handicapés parle en effet d'un trou
d'air dans les moyens en 2002 à l'époque
du changement de gouvernement mais elle
salue également la loire at war 1 de
2005 qui donne le droit à l'école pour
tout enfant handicapé y at-il donc moins
d'enfants handicapés scolarisés
aujourd'hui qu'il ya cinq ans
non leur nombre est passé de 89 milles à
160 milles
mais à droite comme à gauche dans tout
le monde s'accorde pour dire que ce
n'est pas suffisant
non